Mason Disick just proved he's one
protective cousin after Northwest went
live on Tick-Tock against her parents
wishes
on Tuesday Northeast famous mom Kim
Kardashian shared this text she received
from her 12 year old nephew after her
eight-year-old daughter went live on the
social media platform without permission
say yes if you love this app in the
screenshots posted to the kkw beauty
Founders insta story Mason suggests that
North should be supervised when filming
content quote hi I don't want to
disrespect North but I don't think she
should do the lives unless someone is
with her because people are always
screen recording and she might tell
information that isn't correct and stuff
like that that she will regret he went
on citing his own experience with going
live quote I did the exact same thing as
she did I would do the lives and now I
regret saying one of the things that I
said just in case for safety please
stole my my good thing my house
let's give a house tour my Christmas
tree that I did some tick tocks with and
while Mason doesn't go into detail about
what life he regrets we do know that
back in 2020 he went live on Instagram
and revealed Kylie Jenner and Travis
Scott were not back together despite
rumors that they were an item no Kylie
and Travis are not back together but
back to North you just gotta roll with
it Kim praised Mason for being quote so
mature even calling him a quote
insightful King and in a second slide
Kim shared her response to her older
sister Courtney's son Kim writes I
appreciate you looking out Mason and I
agree she felt bad and I don't think she
will do it again but it could be good if
you talk to her about it well Mason
agreed and told his aunt he would love
to chat with North before the reality
star suggested he'd come over for a
sleepover soon which I'm so excited
about of course this all comes after
North filmed a live tick tock on Sunday
giving a tour of her house house without
Kim knowing I'm so much videos yeah no
no no more views
Alive's alive
yeah Kim she wasn't pleased
all my life
okay bye
[Music]
Cam and North launched their joint Tick
Tock account in November you know social
media is such a great tool and the two
have delivered some pretty iconic
mother-daughter content ever since Holy
Spirit activate oh no
[Music]
and Kim despite what she said in the
past I just don't dance okay I make
money moves right
she's dancing people why not so we'll
end things on a high note Kim busting
out her best moves
okay Holy Spirit activate
Holy Spirit activate activate
all right let's go
foreign